primero la guerra en Ucrania y luego el
ataque de jamás han copado toda la
actualidad informativa sin embargo estas
no son las únicas zonas calientes que
podemos encontrar otra región que casi
nunca nos da respiro es el caucaso aquí
en visual politic ya os hemos hablado un
montón de veces de esta pequeña y
conflictiva región Las Guerras de
chechenia y el régimen de kirov la
invasión rusa Georgia en 2008 o el nuevo
papel energético de azerbayán vital para
la Unión Europea en esta ocasión sin
embargo nos vamos a ocupar del posible
fin del conflicto congelado más longevo
de todo el espacio postsoviético
hablamos por supuesto del conflicto de
nagorno karabaj Y es que Seguro seguro
que todos recordáis que hace No mucho
tiempo pudimos ver noticias como esta
azerbayán lanza un ataque contra grupos
separatistas en nagorno kabaj la zona en
disputa con Armenia efectivamente
queridos amigos de visual politic
después de más de 30 años parece que
este amargo conflicto llega de una vez
por todas a su
fin nagorno karabaj que si recordáis
bien es esta pequeña región montañosa
situada entre Armenia y azerbayán y que
está poblada principalmente por armenios
étnicos ha sido tomada por las tropas de
azerbayán y vale puede que muchos os
estéis preguntando Pero esto qué me
importa a mí pues Y si os dijera que la
toma del kabaj por azerbayán supone una
gran Victoria para Turquía y si os
dijera que también es una de derrota
para Rusia es más qué pensaría si os
dijera que esto puede desembocar en un
grave conflicto entre Israel e Irán
queridos amigos por mucho que el
territorio sea pequeño la realidad es
que por esta región pasan infinidad de
intereses internacionales y los
recientes acontecimientos pueden suponer
un serio quebradero de cabeza en la
agenda internacional pero exactamente
qué intereses están en juego en el
caucaso sur Cómo ha llegado azerbayán a
hacerse finalmente con nagorno karabaj
será este el fin de definitivo del largo
conflicto entre Armenia y azerbayán hoy
vamos a responder a todas estas
preguntas pero antes empecemos la
historia por el
principio un conflicto casi
eterno nagorno karabaj es uno de esos
territorios históricos que ha pasado por
diferentes manos a lo largo de la
historia el Imperio mongol el Imperio
otomano el persa sin embargo en ninguno
de estos momentos encontramos el origen
de este conflicto para hacerlo Tenemos
que irnos al comienzo de la unión
soviética con la llegada del régimen
soviético nagorno karabaj que había
declarado su propia Independencia en
1918 y se había negado a formar parte de
la República
transcaucasia socialista soviética de
azerbayán en 1936 como una región
Autónoma desde entonces la disputa entre
armenios y azerí entró en un impaz
auspiciado por la vigilancia central del
kremlin no obstante ante la inminente
caída de la unión soviética en
1988 los habitantes de nagorno kabaj
mayormente des Armenia votaron en un
referéndum para anexionarse a la
República socialista soviética de
Armenia azerbaijan rechazó este
movimiento y mandó sus tropas al
territorio había comenzado la Primera
Guerra del kabaj que acabaría en
1994 tras la mediación rusa se saldó con
cerca de 30,000 vidas perdidas cientos
de miles de desplazados y el control de
nagorno karabaj y de otras siete
provincias colindantes por parte de
Armenia desde aquel momento nagorno
karabaj pasó a ser una de las regiones
más tensas y conflictivas del mundo sí
es cierto Armenia había conseguido que
nagorno karabaj no fuera controlada por
azerbayán pero el régimen aeri no se iba
a dar por
vencido amigos Aunque ambos países
pusieron en marcha diferentes procesos
de negociación para intentar dar con una
solución al conflicto la realidad es que
por motivos históricos ninguna de las
dos partes estuvo dispuesta a dar su
brazo a torcer al final acabó pasando lo
que todo el mundo sabía que iba a pasar
una nueva guerra en 2016 ambos países
probaron de nuevo sus fuerzas con unos
intensos enfrentamientos que duraron 4
días no obstante no fue hasta 2020
cuando volvió a estallar la guerra la
guerra de verdad el 27 de septiembre
azerbayán comenzó a bombardear nagorno
karabaj dio comienzo así la Segunda
Guerra del kabaj que duraría 44 días y
que acabaría con la vida de 4,000
soldados tanto armenios como AC seríes y
provocaría más de 100,000 armenios del
kabaj desplazados esta guerra terminó
con un nuevo acuerdo impulsado otra vez
por Rusia sin embargo en septiembre de
2023 volvimos a ver el rotundo fracaso
de los acuerdos de alto el fuego entre
estos dos países azerbayán rompió la
Baraja y se hizo con el control pero por
qué falló esta vez el acuerdo había
realmente una verdadera voluntad de paz
entre las partes Qué consecuencias puede
tener esta acción Pues bien veámoslo
[Música]
El victorioso
azerbaijan Armenia y azerbayán son como
dos hermanos que no se dan tregua cuando
ambos quieren Lo mismo en este caso
nagorno karabaj a lo largo de los años
han tenido numerosos altos el fuego que
al final siempre se han acabado
rompiendo en mayor o menor medida por
eso la gran mayoría de analistas
acertaron al prever que el alto el fuego
alcanzado en 2020 también acabaría
rompiéndose Y es que mis queridos amigos
de visual politic el acuerdo tuvo serios
problemas desde el
[Música]
principio ya desde el momento de las
negociaciones tanto Armenia como
azerbayán señalaron importantes
incongruencias en el texto del acuerdo
por ejemplo mientras un artículo
permitía a ambos países mantener los
territorios conseguidos en el conflicto
hasta hasta el momento de la firma del
acuerdo otro indicaba la obligación de
La retirada de las tropas armenias no
obstante hubo otros problemas en cuanto
a la aplicación del propio acuerdo
Armenia por ejemplo se negó a la
creación del corredor de zangezur en el
sur del país además ambos países se
negaron a devolver a todos los
desplazados del conflicto a sus hogares
de manera segura incluso con el apoyo de
acnur Y es más Rusia que era la
encargada de supervisar la paz entre
ambos países no logró separar de manera
eficaz a las tropas de estos dos
estados tanto Armenia como azerbayán
eran conscientes del desastre que supuso
el acuerdo y por eso previeron la
posibilidad de un nuevo conflicto en el
futuro de hecho lejos de traer la paz
sabéis qué logró el acuerdo del alto al
fuego del 2020 que ambos países se
armaran aún más de hecho para que os
hagáis una idea en 2020 ambos
invirtieron en torno al 5% de sus pib en
gasto militar por comparar en aquel
mismo año la media global fue del 2,4
por. sin embargo como podéis ver la
inversión en términos absolutos fue
mucho mayor por parte de azerbayán Al
fin y al cabo este país cuenta con un
pib que en 2020 era más de tres veces
superior al de Armenia todo gracias a su
importante sector petrolífero Es más
entre 2011 y 2020 el volumen de
importaciones de armas de azerbayán fue
ocho veces mayor que el de Armenia una
locura Y como seguro que ya os estáis
imaginando entre el fatídico acuerdo de
2020 y el fuerte rearme por parte de
ambos países las tensiones solo fueron
en aumento por ejemplo a mitad de
septiembre de 2022 azerbayán atacó
regiones del sur de Armenia de hecho
aquel mes de septiembre se convirtió en
el mes más hostil desde la guerra de
2020 con casi 300 muertos y 7600
armenios desplazados y no solo eso en
diciembre de 2022 las autoridades
acerías decidieron bloquear el corredor
humanitario de la chin que conectaba
nagorno karabaj con con Armenia lo que
ha tenido serias repercusiones para la
población del kabaj nos morimos de
hambre los habitantes de nagorno karabaj
temen por su futuro bajo el bloqueo la
gente se desmaya esperando por conseguir
pan el bloqueo que tiene 120,000
personas aisladas por el conflicto de
nagorno karabaj las agresiones de
azerbayán confirmaron una sensación casi
absoluta de impunidad azerbayán no
sufrió prácticamente ninguna repercusión
por sus agresiones Y probablemente por
eso el 19 de septiembre de este año 2023
las tropas ha es entraron en masa a
nagorno
karabaj 24 horas fueron las que necesitó
azerbayán para tomar todo el control del
territorio y 24 horas pasaron hasta que
se extendió el temor de una posible
limpieza étnica contra los armenios del
kabaj algo que por supuesto tuvo
consecuencias inmediatas más de 100,000
personas han abandonado nagorno karabaj
unos 120,000 armenios vivían en la
región antes de que azerbayán la
recuperara con la operación Relámpago
que obligó a la disolución de la
República separatista azerbayán ha
insistido en que la decisión de los
armenios étnicos del kabaj de abandonar
el territorio ha sido totalmente
voluntaria sin embargo si echamos un
vistazo al historial del régimen aceri
la realidad es que estas personas
seguramente no tenían otra alternativa
tened en cuenta que azerbayán está
dominada por un régimen autoritario
donde los derechos humanos y las
libertades individuales brillan por su
ausencia un régimen que ha estado
alimentando el odio hacia los armenios
durante décadas y que no ha dudado en
dejarlos de hambre cuando cerró el
corredor de la chin sea como sea lo que
sí sabemos es que azerbayán ya controla
nagorno karabaj parece que el más
longevo de los conflictos post
soviéticos ha llegado a su fin Pero la
pregunta es Cómo afecta esto las
potencias cercanas al caucaso sur de
verdad las hostilidades han acabado de
una vez por todas en esta región pues
veamos si os parece la letra
[Música]
pequeña una guerra fría
caucásica seguramente muchos de vosotros
habréis pensado alguna vez que este
conflicto es más bien intrascendente
algo poco relevante una contienda más en
otra región perdida del mundo sin
embargo queridos amigos amigas de visual
politic la realidad podría ser muy
diferente de hecho sabías que el
conflicto de Armenia y azerbayán por
nagorno karabaj es un vivo reflejo de
las tensiones entre Rusia y Turquía lo
que ha pasado en el kabaj es el perfecto
reflejo de la decadencia rusa y el auge
Turco en la región Por qué pues
fijaos Rusia ha sido sin duda alguna el
actor más activo en el caucaso sur desde
la caída de la unión soviética en 1994
de hecho logró que azerbaijan y Armenia
alcanzaran un alto al fuego no obstante
Rusia se ha mostrado como un mayor apoyo
para Armenia que para azerbaijan por
ejemplo en 1997 ambos países firmaron
una alianza militar permitiendo la
construcción de bases rusas en Armenia
hasta el año 2044 además Armenia también
forma parte de la organización del
tratado de seguridad colectiva que
lidera Rusia sin embargo este apoyo ruso
ha ido deteriorándose los últimos años
en 2020 por ejemplo Rusia decidió
mantener un papel esencialmente neutral
con el fin de preservar sus propios
intereses quizás no debamos olvidar que
Rusia es el principal suministrador de
armas de ambos
países esta misma neutralidad es la que
también ha mostrado Rusia frente al los
recientes acontecimientos probablemente
con la Guerra de Ucrania en marcha
tampoco les quedaba otra Armenia
consciente de esta situación ha buscado
acercarse cada vez más a Washington lo
que por supuesto en moscu no ha sentado
nada bien la traición Armenia como el
gran Aliado de Rusia acabó acercándose a
Estados Unidos el gobierno de Armenia ha
empezado ejercicios militares con
Estados Unidos en medio de un aumento de
tensiones con azerbayán en la guerra de
nagorno kabaj En otras palabras que con
el alejamiento de Armenia de Rusia el
papel del kremlin en el cáucaso sur ha
ido perdiendo cada vez más relevancia y
sabéis Quién ha sabido aprovechar esta
oportunidad efectivamente
[Música]
Turquía Turquía ha sido tradicionalmente
el mejor Aliado de azerbayán en 2009 por
ejemplo firmaron un tratado que les
obligaba a protegerse mutuamente En caso
de que cualquiera de los dos fuera
atacado por otro país y desde luego la
ayuda turca ha llegado a azerbayán sobre
todo en forma de armas cazas f16
vehículos de Infantería dron va irra
actar de hecho los enormes avances de
azerbayán en la guerra de 2020 se dieron
gracias principalmente a toda esta ayuda
turca y a que se debe la ayuda turca
Pues a que Turquía tiene fuertes
intereses en la región intereses que se
han visto favorecidos por la reciente
victoria de cerbán en nagorno karabaj de
qué intereses hablamos pues fijaos en
primer lugar para entender qué Busca
Turquía apoyando a azerbayán tenemos que
entender que el caucaso sur es una zona
desde el punto de vista estratégico
especialmente importante si os fijáis
bien se encu encuentra entre el mar
Negro y el mar caspio es decir controla
el flujo de transporte de la región de
oriente a occidente y viceversa y además
también de norte a sur desde Rusia hasta
otras naciones del océano Índico es
justo este lugar crucial donde Turquía
quiere tener un mayor peso que Rusia con
un único fin conectar con Asia central
Turquía quiere conectar con la enorme
región asiática directamente por el mar
caspio para beneficiarse de las grandes
reservas de gas natural de turkmenistán
y para impulsar nuevos proyectos de
comercio marítimo Pero sabéis qué más le
interesa Turquía en la región pues ni
más ni menos que superar a otra potencia
vecina
Irán y os preguntaréis Qué pinta Irán
aquí pues veréis Irán también está
intentando fortalecer su posición en el
cáucaso sur para poder abrir una nueva
ruta comercial que vaya desde el golfo
Pérsico hasta Georgia y de Georgia
conectar con Rusia y con Europa
atravesando el mar Negro sin embargo en
Terán existe la preocupación de que
azerbayán puede intentar aprovechar su
Victoria frente a Armenia para
expandirse aún más por la región
llegando incluso a bloquear les a los
iraníes el paso hacia Armenia si cerrara
el corredor de zanz segur lo que
desbaratar todos sus planes por eso Irán
se ha posicionado y se seguirá
posicionando a favor de Armenia y claro
la presencia de Irán nunca pasa
desapercibida sabéis que otro país se ha
visto envuelto en todo este lío justo
por el interés de Irán Exacto uno de sus
mayores rivales geopolíticos
Israel de hecho Israel fue en 2020 el
segundo mayor socio comercial de armas
de azerbayán proporcionándole cerca del
2% de las armas al país caucásico no
obstante hasta ahora el papel de Israel
en la región tampoco ha sido tan
determinante como el de Turquía o el de
Rusia Pero eso podría estar a punto de
cambiar con el repentino aumento de las
hostilidades entre Israel y Palestina
tras el brutal ataque terrorista de
hamas El el escenario geopolítico de
oriente próximo y medio está a punto de
volver a convertirse en un hervidero no
debemos olvidar aquí que Irán tiene
fuertes vínculos no solo con el
terrorismo de hezbolá en el Líbano sino
también con jamás en la franja de gaza
de seguir aumentando las hostilidades
entre Israel y Palestina es muy probable
que tanto Israel como Irán intensifiquen
su particular guerra fría hasta el punto
de afectar también al cáucaso sur Israel
apoyando azerbayán e Irán Armenia así
que ya lo veis mis queridos amigos y
amigas de Vial política azerbayán parece
haber acabado de una vez por todas con
el conflicto de nagorno karabaj ya se ha
hecho con todo el territorio y Armenia
no parece tener las fuerzas suficientes
para revertir la situación no obstante
mientras este conflicto se cierra
Armenia y azerbayán corren el riesgo de
verse atrapados en el juego de grandes
potencias como Rusia Turquía Irán o
Israel solo el tiempo nos sacará de
dudas pero hasta entonces La pregunta es
para vosotros creéis que Armenia
intentará tomar nagorno karabaj puede
Rusia recuperar su influencia en el
caucaso sur será esta pequeña región
utilizada como escenario de un conflicto
indirecto entre Irán e Israel podéis
dejarnos vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios como siempre no olvidéis Que
aquí en visual politic sacamos vídeos
nuevos Todas las semanas así que
suscribios a este canal y dadle a la
campanita para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones si os ha
gustado este vídeo dadle al botón de
like y nos vemos en el próximo un saludo
y hasta
pronto
than